[Music]
foreign
selling Christmas toy ever
people do you know what I knew we got
plenty of Turbo man's paintball
oh yes your Christmas spirit
the only thing better than listening to
holiday music gifting and getting
presents and some much needed time off
work is cozying up on the couch and
watching a classic Christmas movie
everyone has their favorites and go-to's
of course and I would go as far to say
that most people's favorite holiday
movies are the ones that they loved or
watched most as a child or maybe it was
just always in the background of a
holiday or Christmas gathering and it
takes you back to simpler times I mean
for me Nostalgia plays a big part in my
holiday viewing choices I just want to
forget everything going on in my real
life and go back to that feeling I had
of being a kid Christmas was just way
more fun then I mean for me anyway I
mean how many times do I have to say I
don't want socks for Christmas Mom
um maybe you need a timeout
kids today
anyway for the first time ever I am here
in the flash for this episode of
countdown giving you my list of my
favorite Christmas movies of all time
all ranked by me the Tomato Meter is
officially on holiday break so sit back
and get ready to hear some wholesome and
probably mostly rotten pics my movie
taste tends to skew towards generally
loved critically rotten as I count down
my favorite Christmas movies of all time
in no particular order well except for
maybe number one so make sure you watch
this until the very end okay here we go
[Music]
starting at number 10 the preacher's
wife
a cleric begins to doubt himself and is
visited by an Angel the Heavenly
Emissary is supposed to help the good
Reverend over his midlife crisis but
he's distracted by the cleric's lovely
young wife a remake with gospel music of
The Bishop's Wife starring Denzel
Washington Whitney Houston Courtney B
Vance and directed by Penny Marshall my
consensus is Denzel Washington acting as
an angel who's basically in love with
the preacher's wife played by Whitney
Houston I mean not only do you get
classic Denzel but it's also basically a
free concert with the greatest singer of
All Time Whitney Houston's vocals I mean
my parents are also very religious they
name me after Jesus of Nazareth if that
gives you any indication so any movie
that alluded to heaven was 100 fresh in
my household all right close your eyes
do you remember
playing in the snow with Hakeem
do you remember what his laugh sounded
like
yeah
do you remember what he looked like
catching a ball
bear that's because when God takes
someone away from us
he leaves what's most important about
that person with us
right here in our hearts
yeah but guys don't miss him well she
still misses him too
are you all right
maybe you should close your eyes
mommy said I can write you
know how to spell his name no you want
to learn yeah all right Hakeem number
nine When Harry Met Sally in 1977
college graduates Harry Burns and Sally
Albright share a contentious car ride
from Chicago to New York during which
they argue about whether men and women
can ever truly be strictly platonic
friends Ten Years Later Harry and Sally
Meet Again at a bookstore and in the
company of their respective best friends
Justin Marie attempt to stay friends
without sex becoming an issue between
them starring Billy Crystal Meg Ryan
Carrie Fisher and directed by Rob Reiner
my consensus is any rom-com holiday
movie that stars Meg Ryan is just an
automatic yes in my book as a 90s kid it
almost feels like a rite of passage When
Harry Met Sally has to be one of the
most iconic romantic comedies ever this
is the perfect movie to watch in that no
man's land time between Christmas and
New Year's where you basically forget
who or what life even is because the New
Year scene in this movie is just the
best
staying over
yes would you like to have dinner
just friends I thought you didn't
believe men and women could be friends
when did I say that on the ride to New
York no no no no I never said this
yes that's right
I can't be friends
unless both of them are involved with
other people then they can this is an
amendment to the early rule the two
people are in relationships the pressure
possible involvement is lifted
that doesn't work either because what
happens then is the person you're
involved with can't understand why you
need to be friends with the person
you're just friends with like it means
something is missing from the
relationship and wanting to go outside
to get it then when you say no no no no
it's not true nothing is missing from
the relationship the person you're
involved with and accuses you being
secretly attracted to the person you're
just friends with which you probably are
make the Mind who the hell are we
kidding let's face it which brings us
back to the early rule before the
amendment which is men and women can't
be friends so what does it leave us
Harry
goodbye
number eight the night before
for the last 10 years lifelong buddies
Ethan Isaac and Chris have gathered on
Christmas Eve to celebrate the holidays
with a bang now as Isaac prepares to
become a first-time father the friends
realize that their annual tradition is
coming to a sad end so to make it as
memorable as possible they basically
plan a night of debauchery and hilarity
by searching for The Nutcracker ball the
Holy Grail of Christmas parties in New
York starring Joseph Gordon-Levitt Seth
Rogen Anthony Mackey and directed by
Jonathan Levine why I love this movie it
actually happens to be my little brother
Chris's favorite holiday movie so it's
because of him that I've watched this a
bunch but the chemistry between Joseph
Gordon-Levitt Anthony Mackey and Seth
Rogen is the best this film is filled
with hilarious scenes and has incredible
cameos from Miley Cyrus Mindy Kaling and
Nathan Fielder and it's really just the
best movie to watch with friends during
the holidays
you okay no I'm not I think the cocaine
the mushrooms are reacting poorly and
now I think I just kind of kind of um
balance it out like I think I'm gonna
make it that I'm more on mushrooms
because I was having fun on mushrooms
look I just I have a plan chill out have
a Red Bull you could also just stop
doing drugs right now like a much much
more mushrooms
are you gonna be cool at this party dude
no you're not cool g you look insane
only your right eye is working there's
gonna be a lot of famous people at this
party and I don't want you to [ __ ] it up
you walk in there looking like a joke
now yes you look weird
still weird
he looks fine no you don't look you need
to check yourself before
before
I wrecked myself is that what you're
saying yes chickity check myself before
I originally recognize you yes that
makes someone feel right to be told that
they might wreck themselves you're not
gonna wreck yourself you made him feel
bad why don't you just leave him alone
no I'm not me look dude why don't you
have some weed and mellow up number
seven Home Alone
when bratty eight-year-old Kevin
McAllister acts out on the night before
family trip to Paris his mother makes
him sleep in the Attic ouch
now after the McAlister's mistakenly
leave for the airport without Kevin he
awakens to an empty house and assumes
his wish to have no family has come true
but his excitement sours when he
realizes that two con men plan to rob
the McAllister residents and that he
alone must protect the family home
starring Macaulay Culkin Joe Pesci
Daniel Stern and directed by Chris
Columbus my consensus is of course this
movie was going to be on the list I mean
this is basically everyone's favorite
Christmas movie of all time and as a
millennial watching it I feel like it's
just as good as it was on my first
viewing of it aside from the part where
I'm basically trying to figure out what
Kevin's parents did for a living to have
that many kids and that big of a house
I'm gonna tell they're dead
morph
Harry
what how'd you take your shoes off
why the hell you dress like a chicken
I'm up here you morons come and get me
you guys give up or you're thirsty for
more
[Music]
heads up
don't worry Marv I'll get them for you
number six You've Got Mail
struggling Boutique Bookseller Kathleen
Kelly hates Joe Fox the owner of a
corporate fox books chain store that
just moved in across the street now when
they meet online however they begin an
intense and Anonymous internet romance
oblivious of each other's true identity
eventually Joe learns that the
enchanting woman he's involved with is
actually his business rival he must now
struggle to reconcile his real life
dislike for her with the Cyber love he's
come to feel starring Tom Hanks Meg Ryan
Parker Posey and directed by none other
than Nora Ephron why I love this movie
so by now you've probably picked up on
the fact that I love Meg Ryan in Holiday
films for me there's also something
about a movie about bookstores during
the holidays it just feels extra cozy
and you just can't beat that Tom Hanks
Meg Ryan chemistry I mean this movie
makes me want to fall in love buy a book
and send an email instead of a text
message
simpler times and again that Nostalgia
of You've Got Mail is really the point
of no return for me
you know sometimes I wonder
what
well
if I hadn't been fox books and you
hadn't been the shop around the corner
and you and I had just met
I know yeah
I would have asked for your number
and I wouldn't have been able to wait 24
hours before calling you up and saying
hey how about
oh how about some coffee or you know
drinks or dinner
or a movie
for as long as we both shall live
[Music]
Joe and you and I would never have been
at War
[Music]
and the only thing we'd fight about
would be which video to run on a
Saturday night
well who fights about that
well some people
not us number five A Charlie Brown
Christmas
Time Is Here happiness and cheer and for
the peanuts fans everywhere it just
wouldn't be Christmas without this
classic holiday Delight Christmas lights
may be twinkling red and green but
Charlie Brown has the Yuletide Blues to
get in the holiday spirit he takes
Lucy's advice and directs the Christmas
play and what's a Christmas play without
a Christmas tree but everyone makes fun
of the short spindly nevergreen Charlie
Brown brings back until the real meaning
of Christmas Works its magic once again
starring Peter Robbins Christopher Shay
Tracy Stratford Sally dryer and directed
by Bill Melendez and Phil Roman why I
love this movie okay so I love jazz and
this film is one of the most iconic
soundtracks of all time it was composed
by the Vince Guaraldi trio and to me it
just isn't Christmas without all the
Charlie Brown characters singing
Christmas Time Is Here fun fact the
album is actually in the Grammy Hall of
Fame and last year it was the number one
greatest holiday 200 album of all time
on Billboard that and learning the real
meaning of Christmas makes this one of
my all-time favorites what's the matter
Charlie Brown don't you think it's great
it's all wrong look Charlie let's face
it we all know that Christmas is a big
commercial racket it's run by a big
Eastern Syndicate you know well this is
one play that's not gonna be commercial
look Charlie Brown what do you want the
proper mood we need a Christmas tree hey
perhaps a tree A Great Big Shiny
aluminum Christmas tree that's it
Charlie Brown you get the tree I'll
handle this crowd okay I'll take Linus
with me the rest of you practice your
lines get the biggest aluminum tree you
can find Charlie Brown maybe painted
pink yeah do something right for a
change Charlie Brown
I don't know Linus I I just don't know
well I guess we better concentrate on
finding a nice Christmas tree
number four jingle all the way
workaholic Howard Langston wants to make
things up to his son Jamie and wife Liz
now he promises to get Jamie the hottest
toy of the Season Turbo Man even though
it's Christmas Eve and the toy is
practically sold out as Langston hunts
Down The elusive gift he runs into
mailman Myron another father on the same
Quest and with a clock winding down
Langston's moral code is tested as he
starts to learn the real meaning of
Christmas starring Arnold Schwarzenegger
Sinbad Phil Hartman Rita Wilson and
directed by Brian Lavon okay so why I
love this movie I think secretly deep
down as a kid I wanted my parents to go
this hard when it came to getting me the
toy I asked Santa for for Christmas and
watching people fight over retail is the
reason why I love shopping movies but
nothing beats watching someone go up
against the Arnold Schwarzenegger for a
toy over the holidays also Sinbad is
just hilarious in this and this film is
Black Friday energy all over it also
Brian Levant directed Mrs Doubtfire and
The Flintstones
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
all right
number three How the Grinch Stole
Christmas
in this live-action adaptation of the
Beloved children's tale by Dr Seuss the
reclusive green Grinch decides to ruin
Christmas for the Cherry citizens of
Whoville reluctantly joined by his
hapless dog Max the Grinch comes down
from his Mountaintop home and sneaks
into town to swipe everything holiday
related from the who's however the
bitter Grump finds a hitch in his plans
when he encounters the endearing Cindy
Lou Who starring Jim Carrey Jeffrey
Tambor Christine baransky and directed
by Ron Howard as in Aries I really just
identify with the Grinch and really all
think Seussical I'm a huge fan of that
whole world and I think we got the
greatest Christmas gift of all time when
Jim Carrey took on this iconic role as
the Grinch there's something about him
in green that just feels right if you
love The Mask you know what I mean fun
fact Jim actually went on The Graham
Norton Show and shared that the first
day on set he spent eight hours in hair
and makeup to transform into the Grinch
and literally told Ron Howard that he
couldn't do the movie they ended up
hiring a CIA operative to teach Carrie
how to endure torture and that's what
got him through making this movie what a
Grinch
now park her up and kiss it
[Music]
oh somebody's fabulous
[Music]
yeah
let's go
excuse me
mind if I wet my wish well
that's my good stuff
number two the holiday
two women one from America and one from
Britain swap Homes at Christmas time
after bad breakups with their boyfriends
now each woman finds romance with a
local man but realizes that the imminent
return home may end the relationship
starring Cameron Diaz Kate Winslet Jude
Law Jack Black and directed by none
other than Nancy Myers why I love this
movie so as a hopeful romantic the
holidays always make me feel extra
hopeful and as someone who's been single
for a lot of her life no holiday movie
has ever made me feel really seen quite
like the holiday why Kate Winslet's
opening monologue about unrequited love
has to be one of my favorite opening
lines to a film ever and you just can't
be a Nancy Meyer holiday special I mean
you got Cameron Diaz Jack Black Kate
Winslet Jude Law amazing homes romance
and Eli Wallach as the old man neighbor
who just makes your heart want to burst
it is the best
I'm in love with you
I apologize for the blunt delivery
problematical as this fact maybe I am in
love
with you
and I'm not feeling this because you're
leaving and not because it feels good to
feel this way which by the way it does
or did before you went off like that I
can't figure out the mathematics of this
I just know I love you
can't believe how many times I'm saying
it
and I never thought I'd feel this way
again so that's pretty phenomenal and I
realize I come with a package deal
three for the price of one and my
package perhaps in the light of day
isn't all that wonderful but I finally
know what I want and that in itself is a
miracle
and what I want
is you
and finally number one The Nightmare
Before Christmas
the film follows the Misadventures of
Jack Skellington halloweentown's beloved
Pumpkin King who has become bored with
the same annual routine of frightening
people in the quote real world when Jack
accidentally stumbles on Christmas Town
all bright colors and warm Spirits he
gets a new lease on life he plots to
bring Christmas under his control by
kidnapping Santa Claus and taking over
the role but Jack soon discovers that
even the best laid plans of mice's
skeleton men can go seriously awry
starring Danny Elfman Chris Randon
Catherine O'Hara and directed by Henry
Selleck this film is truly my number one
favorite holiday movie I love all things
Tim Burton and the music is so iconic I
mean I don't understand how this is in a
Broadway show year round like why isn't
this on Broadway make it make sense the
animation is striking it is the perfect
film to watch with the whole family sing
along to and you can get away watching
it on Halloween to get you right in the
spirit for Christmas also we should just
officially change Santa Claus's name to
anti-class
[Music]
Santa
[Music]
Santa
[Music]
Merry Christmas
and what is your name
[Music]
that's all right I have a special
present for you anyway
there you go sonny
[Music]
and what did Santa bring you honey
Merry Christmas
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I am your host Naz Perez and
thanks for letting me share my favorites
with you before I go I do want to give a
mini shout out to the movie The Santa
Claus starring Tim Allen which is also a
favorite of mine and since Disney plus
is coming out with a spin-off Series
this year I think it's worth mentioning
before I leave you I'll definitely be
checking that one out until next time my
friend and I'll see you back here for
more top tens on the Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
foreign
[Music]